and today we will go over one of very
nice wins by Bobby Fischer and this game
he played against a strong player from
us Rubin fine and it's a it's only a 17
moves this game but you'll see some very
nice ideas that Fischer did in this game
and after that we will do some tactical
ideas that we usually do different
tactical motifs could be double check
discovery many different ideas yes you
have a question
uh-huh
okay great great yeah just look at the
games and you will learn a lot
definitely so that's why we will go over
one of his games so Fisher is playing
with the white pieces and Reuben fine is
black and I will be asking you to find
the moves and please only raise your
hand don't have to make any noise just
raise your hand I will see the you
raising your hand and I'm a velasca okay
so let's do that so II 4 E 5 9 f3 knight
c6 Bishop c4 Bishop c5 and here if you
played this move before anybody know
what's the name of this opening when he
plays before what is white trying to
play here yes very good this is the
Evans gambit when you sacrifice a pawn
in the opening it's considered a gambit
and here white is sacrificing a pawn in
order to get some initiative okay now
taking away the night it's bad because
if you take with the night white can
just simply take the pawn only 5 so
that's why usually black takes Bishop
takes before an idea is why play c3
gaining a temple on the bishop now
Bishop goes back to a5 and now d4
by losing upon now White has a control
of the center okay
now II takes d4 plate
he takes d4 plate and now white castle's
and see black is just black is just
capturing the pawns but the problem here
is white or is it developed and black
still needs to develop his knight and
the king is in the middle of the board
so here if you're playing with the white
pieces what do you think what's the best
move here for white to activate the
piece develop a piece and also create a
threat immediately so think about it a
little bit there are a few different
moves you can try to do but which move
would be the best here let's see
okay yes which see bishop we have two of
them here so aha yes you can go to g5
that's a possibility but he probably can
just play this move just going to go
here okay you have something better here
something better
yes
haha
well if you go here he could take you so
you could go here possibly but still
there is something better you have here
yes
bishop a tree that's a possibility you
can do that but again we're not really
threatening anything immediately so the
next move you play you immediately
threaten something okay so you need to
find that move you develop a piece and
you attack something go ahead 93 but the
bishop can take it see so let's see okay
just raise your hand yeah okay go ahead
yeah that's a developing move that's a
developing move but it's it's not it's
not attacking anything so I need you to
develop one of your pieces and increase
the pressure I mean yeah you're
attacking the pawn yeah but that pawn is
protected it's a strong move very strong
move here you need to find ninety four
it's possible but better something
better you need to develop yes
yeah but they should be too Oh can he
just take it
see you know you know you don't want to
lose the bishop here yeah you don't want
to lose a bishop yeah for just a pawn
okay yes go ahead
uh-huh cling to b3 the reason this move
is very strong because you develop your
queen and also you're attacking the pawn
on a stone immediately you're creating a
threat so he needs to do something to
defend against this threat well you
could also do that you could also go
Queen d5 but most likely he's going to
go Queen e7
okay so yeah
so queen bee 3 now he played Queen e7
and now Fischer took the pawn on c3
because now he's trying to go Knight d5
ok
do what
AHA atrium in well you could do that but
he just plays d6 and it's blocking the
diagonal so so he took on c3 black
should have taken the night but then
Queen takes c3 white still has a very
active position so he played Knight f6
and this is a mistake now can you find
the best move for white to take
advantage of this mistake Knight f6
think about it first for few minutes try
to calculate some lines and then you can
raise your hand
so his king is in the middle of the
board yeah so you have to try to take it
down to do it since the king is in the
middle of the board here yes yeah huh
but if you take the p7 Bishop is
protecting it see you'll lose your queen
don't rush don't rush see you need a
very active move here you need a very
active move let's see yes excellent
Knight d5 activating the Queen
I'm sorry activating the knight now
attacking on the Queen and the night so
he takes now you have a choice you can
take back with the bishop or you can
take back with the pawn okay just just
just raise your hand
just raise your hand what do you think
take back with the bishop or take back
with a pawn yes pawn absolutely you want
to take back with the pawn because you
you want to open up the e-file for your
rook okay so that's why you want to take
back with the pawn if you take back with
the bishop you're not really attacking
anything because the knight is protected
okay so you want to take back with the
pawn you attack the knight okay now
he played 95 so now you capture it
captures now you need to find another
move here to develop a piece and also
attack now which move you have to find
here for white what do you think to
develop a piece and attack one of the
black pieces yes
you could play that but see through
history threatening to take your rock
you have to see his threat he is trying
to take your rock so that move will also
help you to develop a piece okay develop
a piece and attack yes yes you want to
put the bishop here but what if he takes
he could take you and see he is guarding
this square this idea would have been
great if the bishop wasn't there but the
bishop is you would have win the Queen
but in this case you can because he
takes that
okay okay now what do you need to do
here what you need to do here think
about it it's a nice move you need to
find yes correct
Bishop with you Bishop b2 attacking on
the Queen and developing a piece now he
needs to move the Queen yes Queen g5 e
plate because you want to win this pawn
on g7 but the Queen is protecting it so
now you need to find a move to deflect
the Queen in order to win the g7 pawn
so which move you can play here to try
to deflect the Queen so you can win the
g7 pawn here yes
you could pay queen g3 but the thing is
with with the queen g3 he can just take
you Shh please
I will answer the questions yeah so only
raise your hand first if I call you then
you can say the lines okay because so
many of you today I know we have a
tournament but we have a lot of you so I
need only raise your hand first and then
you can say lines okay now if takes see
black hand castle now
and he's going to be able to escape so
that's why we don't want to play Queen
g3 here something that we can attack
immediately
yes yeah pawn f4 is a possibility he
played a little bit different panic for
is weakening the diagonal so maybe that
he played h4 instead
attacking the Queen now Queen takes h4
and now since we already deflected the
Queen what can we do Bishop takes g7
correct rook g8 now when the king is in
the middle of the board you don't want
to waste any moves you have to try to
find a way to checkmate them and his
King is very weak here so what can you
do first what can you do here first
basically in just few moves Fischer is
going to make his opponent here so let's
see if you can find it okay
Luke you want check check okay
he did play rook everyone check I know
you think it's the bad move because
Bishop can take it but the king is in
the middle of the board so it's okay you
can lose the exchange here but you have
very good mating chances now so he's
going to have to take correct
now I take back without the rook check
he can still go here it's not checkmate
yet and now think about it
don't rush can you find a move after
which black resigned here because he's
going to get checkmated in two moves
why to play a very strong laughter which
you just resigned
there are many moves you have but this
one is the most precise move here
okay go ahead aha Bishop to f6 you are
you have the right idea but if we go
right away he can take you see that's
the idea we want to go Bishop f6 and
that will be a checkmate but we cannot
do right away because Queen can take it
okay so you have to do something first
okay that will be great if we can find a
way to distract the Queen but how okay
let's see okay C pawn to g3 it looks
like you're attacking my queen but in
fact I can take the bishop because I
will be pinning the Queen at the King so
you cannot take back my Queen because of
the pin here okay so what can you do
here
yes the rookie four but can I just take
it aha
I can just take it there so we cannot
play rookie four yet so let's say yes
Quincy three that's a good move
that's a good move you could play this
move but you have something better
something better here because we need to
find a way to way attack his queen
because if his Queen moves away from
that diagonal we can go Bishop f6 and
checkmate them so what can we do here
okay yes Queen to e3 but you're not
attacking the Queen you need to attack
the Queen yes excellent Queen to g3
that's what Fischer played and his
opponent resigned here let's see why if
it takes the Queen what do you do six
checkmate
okay okay let's do that let's see if
rook takes the bishop then we take the
Queen check f6 check and then we go
checkmate so this is the game t-shirt
against Reuben fine from 1963 okay it's
a very famous game and who is Bobby
Fischer anybody know yes who is it okay
but what's the biggest accomplishment he
had
no no it deeply deep blue let's see what
yes Volo champion anywhere was he from
okay from us
no not Russia no he's not from Russia
for sure okay now okay let's see now
we're going to do some tactics okay and
on mix motifs so white to play you need
to listen carefully so you know what you
need to do here white to play okay wait
with white to play checkmate in two okay
let's for a few minutes I want you to
think first before you raise your hand
ends down think first and then when you
have it then you can raise your hand for
sure why to play checkmate e2 if you
look at the position you're actually
down a rock and upon because black has
two rooks okay so that's why you have to
do something very strong here otherwise
you're going to lose this game so you
need something very strong here okay
so white to play checkmate into a very
nice idea here you can try to do
yes in the back better better you're
very close you're very close but you
need something better you have to try to
check because if you don't trick you're
going to give me a break to start
checking and checking you you see a
check or is it you have a check here hmm
okay let's see yes yeah yeah yeah Queen
takes h6 check right now what can black
do here
can you go here Knight is guarding it
you can't so you cannot do anything so
you sacrifice your queen so he has to
take back with the pawn and after he
takes what do you do
rook - h7 checkmate
so by sacrificing the Queen you move
this all you needed to do in this
position to win you need to do move this
pawn from here so by sacrificing the
Queen you accomplish that goal it takes
and then you go rook h7 mate okay great
now white to play white is down actually
two pounds so looks like he's in trouble
here but actually white can checkmate
here in three moves white to play
checkmate in three
what can you do here to checkmate in
three moves
okay yeah I'll give you I'll give you a
little bit more time one or two minutes
more to think on this one you're down
two pounds here and if you cannot do
anything then he will just convert this
advantage right and win the game but you
can do something here what can you do
something very nice it's a brilliant
idea here and you checkmate in three
moves checkmate in three moves let's see
okay let's see you yeah
Misha page 7 check King takes h7 a
bishop is here
you'll take you yeah but that's already
two moves right that's two I move the
King again
you can take but you know it's not going
to be a trick mate okay
something better you have here something
better than be straight 7 it's a
combination ok ok yes but he's going to
start checking you now check once he
starts checking you now he's going to
maybe even when you're Quinn here with
some pin now you're under a check you
cannot move your Bishop so we cannot
that so you have to try to do something
better you have something better here
let's see ok listen
group captures g7 check very good now
for a moment it looks like you can just
take the rook right so let's see if
there is a good follow up he has to take
continue Queen to f7 check now what can
he do what's the only move you can try
to do came to h8 that's it see so this
is a typical idea and you need to get
used to this idea so you can find this
kind of checkmate in your games as well
ok so let's go back again to see how
this idea works we start out with rook
g7 check rook g7 check this is very very
important now King takes g7 check King
has to go back to h8 and rook h7 mate
what this idea does it removes the
defender ok you remove the defender the
defender is this pawn so you sacrifice
your rook to remove the defender then he
doesn't have a defense and then you
follow it up with queen h7 Queen f7
check and then Queen h7 checkmate
ok that's a very very nice idea here ok
I want everybody to be focused
and white to play checkmate in two if
you look carefully in the position
you're done a rook here and upon and if
it's blocked to play what can black do
here
Queen to GQ or H to checkmate okay so
whatever you do it has to be very quick
otherwise he's going to go there and
checkmate
and doesn't look like we can check made
him here because we cannot go Queen g7
rook takes it we cannot go to Cafe it
because Knight exit okay so for a moment
looks like we are losing but you have a
very nice move here it's hard to see
this move that's why I wanted to you to
do this exercise so see if you can find
this move here white can checkmate here
in two moves actually maybe maybe three
moves in one line but it's it's same
same type of mate so let's see here if
you can find a move here
don't rush when you see an answer just
double-check down to make sure you have
a dancer it's correct okay let's see
white to play
checkmate e to go ahead Queen B head
very good Queen B a check now looks like
black and just simply take it right he
can just take the queen but when he
takes the Queen C the night on December
was guarding this important square so
after he takes he's no longer
controlling this square so what can we
do look to f8 checkmate C and the night
rook is checking the knight is
protecting the rook and King cannot come
up on g7 because of the mate okay now
and if you place he cannot come up
because on a foul rook is guarding it
and he cannot come here nice guy so he
can try to go rook e8 what do you do
then check
he goes here very good okay this is
since you did very well on the other
ones let's see if we can solve this one
white to play no no I don't I don't want
anybody raise their hands for the next
few minutes okay because this is a
difficult one white to play checkmate in
three
white to play checkmate in three just
just check your answer first it's not
it's not like it's no it's checkmate in
three pink first ink first I told you
it's difficult if you think it's going
to be like the other ones no this is
much more difficult I want to do
something very difficult now let's see
okay go ahead uh-huh see that's why I
was saying don't rush still mate draw I
can move the king I cannot move the H
pawn it's blocked and I cannot move the
Jeep on because it spin so that's I
don't rush okay nothing it's checkmate
in three moves
so first move is a very special move
very special move okay let's see okay go
ahead okay
again draw thank you for the draw yeah
see you two-piece up if you have two
extra pieces you draw it's not good
it's like you you give away half a point
okay okay yes f5 f7
yeah these are winning moves you will
win the game here by playing the small
but you're not going to be able to win
in three moves this will take you a lot
longer because I move away then you will
probably win this pounce and checkmate
but it will take a lot of moves okay but
here you can we need three moves it's
not an easy position this is actually a
lot of lot of chess players have a hard
time with this so let's see if you can
find this move
the problem is it's a stalemate here if
you don't do anything if you don't do
anything very strong it's going to be
still made now what can you do here
let's see yes in the back yeah but we
remember right we talked about that it's
still made if you move your king
anywhere on the board it's still made
see you go here I have no moves I have
no legal moves and if I don't have law
legal moves it to draw you cannot make
me make an illegal move still mate okay
let's see yes yeah no yeah yeah
again 925 you will probably win this
game because 905 is a good move in fact
if you go 95 you will win the game by
winning the spot but it will take you at
least 20 30 moves to checkmate with the
bishop and night and you have to know
actually how to do it so take you a long
time that's the second best move in this
position second best but who can find
the best move here see what you need to
do is you need to find a move that will
break the stalemate
yeah but how can you our pin we can't
really unpin here there's only one way
only one way to do it yes
same thing still made so we can't move
the King sir let's try to find this move
by method of elimination now use your
pressure we can't move the King guys
guys quiet here
lots of noise from here okay just raise
your hand yeah so we can't move the King
if we move the knight we probably going
to win the game but it's gonna take you
a lot longer so we have the bishop left
right yes Bishop g7 but the thing is if
you take now my king is going to escape
from the corner and with a single knife
you cannot win now you cannot make me
with a single night in this position
you're very close but think very close
huh see this is a tough one
okay
yes you could do that but it will take
you longer you will win the game but it
will take you like maybe 10 15 20 moves
to win it goes 90 f7 I go here we don't
have a mate here it takes you take a
longer to win much longer yes
the bishop to f6 aha
excellent very good Bishop to f6 now
black has only one move here I have to
take the bishop right no choice I have
to take the bishop now very very
important move you have to find here
because he's trying to escape with a
king what are you going to do here
follow it up not yet
remember he wants to escape guys listen
aha so you go King f8 now now King is in
the box you cannot escape but it's not a
STEMI because you can push the spawn
without this point it would have been a
draw but with this pawn now he has to
push f5 and now what do you do
last move Knight f7 yeah 90 texts upon
it will be drier because he will play h5
and we cannot meet him anymore so we go
Knight to f7
checkmate now his pawns are now going
this way okay but it's still a still
made position and this movement no
longer works because he cannot take his
pants are going down so it's still made
white to play checkmate in three again
well black is trying to get a stalemate
because still maybe will be a draw but
you don't want to steal maybe two extra
pieces you want to win here you need to
again think of an idea to do something
to break the stalemate exactly but the
problem is if you move the bishop here
I cannot take because my pants are going
down now this is not a legal move I can
do this so it will be a stalemate so now
you have to find a different move to
break the stalemate here again this is
advanced very advanced position for you
well but you want to work on that yeah
you don't want to just still mate okay
what can you do here yes my to be one
here but you acquaints see here taken
Queen
now you need to find a move to break the
stalemate here first
again if you move your night you
probably win but it will take you longer
much longer to win now let's see who can
find it yes Bishop this human b2 but
then he takes then you go here then he
Quinn's you take it takes draw you'll be
a joyeux you want to win with two extra
pieces you want to win right you don't
want to draw it to extra pieces what can
you do to break the stalemate so he can
have a move to make here huh what can
you do let's see yes now you see two is
a possibility but he just goes here it
just goes here that's one already and
now it's checked you cannot Quinn you
checked you check so it's not a knight
move with the night we cannot win if we
move now let me say about the king you
could have moved the King in the
previous position that's still making
the one King the one is a still mad yes
very close you want to go here but here
I have no moves it will be still mate
because I don't have moves you're close
very close
yes
here here but if you it will be still
made because I cannot do anything I
cannot push the palm and cannot do
anything so it will be a stalemate we
need to do something yes correct
king c3 now we get in front of our
Bishop and for a moment it looks like
wait a minute he can just queen now he
will win the game so he's going to Queen
now what do you do mating - now mating -
yes go ahead
Knight takes Queen you can take you a
little bit a little better better okay
check King is in the corner right no
squares to go to he has to take takes
King texty - checkmate
see in order to checkmate here in - in
three moves you have to get your King
actually in front of your bishop okay so
go King c3 he Queens and then you go
nicely to check takes Cinci - okay okay
good job everybody